[The Science and Art of Obstetrics, by Joseph B. DeLee, M.D. ]
[These pictures were taken at the Chicago Lying-in Hospital in affiliation with the University of Chicago.]
[...]
[Dr. DeLee:] Ladies and gentlemen, today we will talk on the forceps operation,
and we will begin with a brief pictorial history of the instrument.
May we have the slides, please.
Jan Palfijn, anatomist and surgeon-obstetrician of Kortrijk, Belgium invented a forceps in 1720.
He walked the 180 miles to Paris to publish his blessing for womankind.
True, an Englishman, son of a French Huguenot, named Peter Chamberlen, about 1580 devised a good forceps,
but he and his descendants kept it a trade secret.
Chamberlen has no monument, but Palfijn is remembered.
In Ghent, a pregnant woman weeps on his tomb.
And in Kortrijk, his birthplace, stands this heroic bronze.
Next, please.
Here is the crude instrument he contrived, a pair of heavy iron spoons, placed parallel and tied with a handkerchief when used.
[...]
Chamberlen's forceps, a very practical instrument, discovered in an old garret in 1815.
It is too bad the family did not give it to humanity.
This round forceps dates 150 years before Christ.
The Royal College of Surgeons and the Wellcome Historical Museum of London
kindly let me photograph the forceps in their collection.
Rueff forceps, 1522.
Note impractical lock. The hook, probably for dead fetuses.
Pugh's forceps, an English forceps with the pelvic curve, 1740, the English lock.
Levret's forceps, a French long instrument.
Levret also invented a pelvic curve, and the French screw lock.
Busch's forceps. Busch added the hook on the handle to facilitate traction,
and introduced the German or pin lock.
The great William Smellie of Scotland, about 1750, invented several forceps,
a crude wooden affair and others both short and long. All covered with soft leather.
Levret, a contemporary, objected to the leather, saying it could convey infection.
A few bizarre models, hook for the breech.
Anterior/posterior blade. Anterior/posterior blade, English lock.
End is padded, like fingers for a rotation, possibly.
Isometric blade.
Ring for easier traction.
Asynclitic blades for asynclitic heads.
Barton forceps, 1928. See the hinge on the anterior blade.
With this instrument you can pull down in the axis of the inlet.
A three-bladed forceps with a hinge here.
Don't invent a pair of forceps until you have seen the 600 models published by Kedarnath Das of Calcutta.
A vest pocket model, folded.
A combination vectis sharp and blunt hook.
The genial Simpson, who gave women anesthesia and did much else for obstetrics.
I recommend his forceps presented in 1848.
We now come to the important principle of axis traction.
The pelvic floor curve prevents us from pulling down in the axis of the inlet with the ordinary forceps.
Older obstetricians, in order to get around this pelvic floor curve, invented instruments that had crooked shanks or bent levers, like this.
When you pull in the axis of the inlet with the ordinary forceps, part of the fork is exerted against the pubis, damaging the pubis,
the head, the vagina, and cervix, and the bladder, particularly the bladder.
When you use this kind of an instrument, you can secure axis traction, avoiding these damages.
This is the first axis traction instrument.
Pulled down through the handle, this pump arches the perineum.
Note the hinges in the blade, this confers mobility on the head, lets it work up and down.
This is a bent-lever forceps. This is the arch for the perineum.
You pull on the handle here.
Tarnier of Paris did the most for the axis traction principle and invented a hundred models of forceps.
But now, hardly anybody uses them, because the high forceps operation is being done very little.
This is his first model, a rather clumsy instrument, with numerous bends.
This, his latest model.
Force applied here at this joint, through this joint, to the head.
A rather inartistic procedure, in my opinion.
Lights, please.
I will now show you how we can obtain axis traction with the ordinary or straight instrument.
Here is the inlet. This is the axis of the inlet.
This is the pelvic floor curve. We want to pull in this direction.
First we do a deep episiotomy. That obliterates the pelvic floor curve and straightens the canal.
Then, aided by Pajot's maneuver, we can pull down, and around, and out, and make the head follow the path of least resistance.
Saxthorpe in 1772 devised a movement by combining traction downward, outward, and upward at the same time.
Pajot popularized it. And I will show it to you on this model.
You pull down, here and you pull upward and out there.
And with each traction, you fuse the two motions into one smooth movement, like this.
In 1915, Kielland of Norway, over there it is pronounced Jelland, invented this instrument.
Like all modern forceps, it embodies principles discovered by the pioneers.
It is recommended for the high transverse head, in face and brow presentation,
in occipital posterior as a rotator, and when the head is asynclitic.
The instrument is getting considerable vogue.
And I use it occasionally, but not often.
This is Sir James Y. Simpson's forceps, the one that I recommend to you for general practice.
I have made the shanks longer to keep the operating hand away from the infected anus.
And also to make it a more universal instrument for high, as well as low operations.
I also lightened the handle, so as to balance the instrument more evenly.
Now, gentlemen, it is not the forceps, but it is the man behind the forceps that counts.
And if you will know the anatomy of the pelvis, and the mechanism of labor,
you will be able to do with this instrument, everything that it is safe to do with any other.
Now, before going on to the forceps operation, I want to tell you about episiotomy, which I do in all primipari and many multipari.
It not only saves the baby's brain from compression and congestion, but it also
preserves the pelvic floor and the connective tissue framework of the pelvis.
And you know, damage to this structure often results in rectocele, cystocele, and descent of the uterus.
You will watch an episiotomy on the living much more understandingly
if you first see it done on these models.
I prefer the medial lateral episiotomy. Squeeze the sphincter away.
Begin in the middle line. I am cutting the skin and urogenital septum.
This exposes the intercolumnar fascia.
I am separating the vagina from the fascia.
I am cutting the vagina.
I cut the intercolumnar fascia on the levator ani pillar, higher up than the episiotomy,
in order to leave a larger portion of the levator on the rectum. It is easier to sew.
That is the urogenital septum. That is the other side. There is the cut fascia, and here the other side.
I am now cutting the levator ani muscle itself, a little nick for a small baby,
much deeper for a large baby, or a rigid pelvic floor.
The levator flattens out as you cut it. Remember that when you sew.
Here lies the sphincter ani, but in life you can't see it unless it is torn.
We will now do the repair.
I use figure of eight silkworm gut. And I recommend it, because I believe it is the best for general practice.
The first vaginal suture, sew the vagina high in the pelvis where it belongs.
Take care to include the fascia.
This is the holding stitch, it keeps the vagina out of the way.
Now, lift up the intercolumnar fascia and the levator with Allis forceps.
The finger goes into the rectum to push the rectum up into the pelvis and to prevent the needle
from going through the mucosa of the rectum.
The deep loop of the first suture is in, the second of the figure of eight stitches.
The three figures of eight are now in.
We cross the stitches, being careful not to lock them in the depth of the wound.
Now, for the outer loop of the figure of eight.
Pull out the urogenital septum from its retracted position.
Get a good bite of the tissue so as to close off dead spaces in the bottom of the wound.
Dead spaces breed infection.
Pull out the tissue, take a little of the fascia here to close off the ischiorectal fossa.
This is the second loop of the first figure of eight.
[...]
The second loop of the second figure of eight.
Always take a little fascia here to close dead spaces.
They fill with blood and breed infection.
[...]
The wound gapes a little at the bottom.
Put in a stitch to close the ischial rectal fossa.
Pull out the tissue carefully on the right, be a little careful of the sphincter.
A traction diverticulum may be punctured.
[...]
Now, for the important crown feature. It prevents a gaping vulva.
We will use a larger model here.
Skin constrictor coming...pull it out. It retracts into the depths of the wound.
[...]
The fascia under the vagina...be careful, don't puncture the vagina.
Now, the same on the right side.
Pull the tissues out, take a good big bite.
[...]
Vaginal holding stitch. Twist all of the sutures into a bundle with a knot so they stand up away from the anus.
Cut close to the knot so that the ends do not hurt the patient.
[...]
[Nurse:] Dr. Davis wishes you in the birth room please.
[Dr. DeLee:] Thank you. A primipara, age 38, married 10 years, in labor.
Membranes ruptured 20 hours,
first stage 18 hours, second stage two hours, occiput right, 90 degrees.
Station plus 2.
Deep transverse arrest. No progress.
Fetal heart tones 160, 120, 140.
The heart rate does not always tell us what we would like to know about the baby.
I think forceps is indicated. Davis.
A second stage lasting two hours, that means that Davis
has been waiting for spontaneous, anterior rotation to occur.
It has not, and dangers are beginning to accumulate.
Remember, prolonged labor has many harmful effects, both physical and biochemical.
Some temporary, and some permanent on both mother and child.
Let us adjourn to the birth room, and in the meantime, you might be thinking over the indications and the conditions for forceps.
[...]
Before deciding to operate, you must always make your own diagnosis.
Uterus, rather rigid and tender. Occiput right transverse.
The left round ligament, somewhat tender. Tense.
The right round ligament, also.
That is the retraction ring, near the navel, that's normal.
You can count the heartbeat.
[Sound of baby's heartbeat]
About 100, strong, regular. But we know her heart is normal, and her other organs too.
She has been given good prenatal care and has been prepared physically and mentally for her ordeal.
The doctor must know the exact condition of his patient, as she stands on the threshold of her labor.
Has she been having been pains like that very long?
[Dr. Davis:] Yes, over two hours, but she is discouraged, her pains do no good, and her efforts are getting weaker.
[Dr. DeLee:] It looks like a good size baby, I'd guess about 9 pounds.
High up, I feel a rim of cervix left. Only a rim.
The vaginal suture is in the transverse diameter.
Small fontanelle on the right, large fontanelle on the left.
Synclatism perfect.
Deep transverse array.
Oh, yes, dehydration. Tongue is rather dry.
I thought I'd missed a beat, but no.
Her color is good.
I'd like to wait for a complete rotation, but progress has stopped.
The woman is 38, and we must think of the baby too.
The conditions are all satisfied.
There is no disproportion between the head and the toes.
The bag of waters is ruptured.
The child is living. The cervix is dilated, fully.
The head is engaged, well-engaged.
We do not wait to see what the woman can endure, but what she can accomplish,
Barnes of London said that.
We will start the anesthetics when we are nearly ready.
Use as little anesthesia as possible.
We often use pudendal, or local.
Watch the heart tones, there is a tendency to abruptio placentae at this time.
Primum non nocere.
First of all, do no damage.
Non vi sed arte.
Not with force.
[Baby crying ]
There are seven things to do before leaving the house.
Don't forget them.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
One, see that the uterus is hard and not inverted.
The uterus is firm below the naval.
Examine both broad ligaments.
You may find a hematoma or a twisted ovary. Rare, but worth thinking about.
See the contraction of the uterus beginning.
Two, see that there is no hemorrhage, external or internal.
No, the pad is dry.
Three, see that the placenta is complete.
Well, we've done that.
Four, see that all lacerations are attended to.
We've done that.
Five, see that the bladder is empty.
We have emptied it.
Six, see that the mother is in good condition.
Her pulse is good,
better than it was at the beginning of the operation.
Her color is good. She has not lost much blood.
Seven, see that the baby is in good condition.
Miss Carman says it is.
Everything is fine.
How much did the baby weigh?
[Nurse:] Eight pounds, nine ounces.
[Dr. DeLee:] You see the head is drawn out, Dolichocephalus.
Typical molding for ODT.
Those marks on the baby's head, those red streaks,
will disappear in a few days.
They show that the forceps were lying in the proper position.
The right parietal lies a little bit under, uh, over the left.
It is a boy, and since we have delivered him without damage to his brain, he ought to make a good citizen.
Ladies and gentlemen, I will meet you tomorrow and we will discuss this case further. In the meantime, ponder over what you have seen.
Good morning. Our patient of yesterday is doing very well, and so is the baby.
The older obstetricians, when they reported their cases, used to write down their reflections.
What they did right, what they did wrong, and what they would do if they had the case to do over again.
Let us review some of the things we did yesterday. First the rotation.
The baby lay occipital right posterior, occipitodextra 135 degrees.
Nature had brought the occiput into the transverse, where the rotation was arrested.
I simply completed the rotation, bimanually, and applied forceps like this.
Occiput right 135 degrees.
The small fontanelle must travel 3/4 of a half-circle.
[...]
Push the head up out of its embedment in the narrow pelvic region.
Turn it by combined manipulation.
[...]
Hold the head by either hand, or a light clamp such as an Allis forceps, affixed to the scalp while you apply the blade.
I always try to do with my hands everything possible. The fingers have eyes.
A few words about the key and lock maneuver. Nature, when she advances the head through the birth canal,
forces it down, turns it a little to the front, and relaxes.
The head lowers in the pelvis, rotates a bit, and then retreats.
And thus, in gradual stages, the occiput is brought to the front under the pubis.
When we try to imitate nature in persistent occiput posterior, and fail with our fingers, we have to use forceps.
And the movements we impart to the instrument, resemble those we use when we try to turn a key in a stubborn lock.
That is why I called it the key and lock maneuver. Perhaps some of you will give me a better name for it.
Let us do the little operation on this half pelvis.
Occiput, right posterior. You may have to apply the forceps obliquely.
Push up a little, twist a little, pull down a little. Readjust the blade.
Push up a little, twist a little, move down a little, readjust the blade.
You adjust, you bring the occiput around in easy stages, 10 or 15 degrees of the circle each time.
The rotation being completed, from now on the case is the usual low forceps operation.
[Observer:] Doctor? Is it always so easy to locate the head?
[Dr. DeLee:] Oh, no. Sometimes it is very hard.
You may have to push the head up out of the pelvis, and rotate the back to the front, or even to the opposite side of the abdomen, like this.
[...]
Left occiput posterior this time. Raise the head above the inlet.
Gently! Force is dangerous. Spread the fingers over the shoulders and back.
This is the back.
Turn the back to the front. Carefully.
Lead the head down into the pelvis with both hands
or draw it into the pelvis with forceps, perhaps leaving the case then to nature.
Rarely, in transversely contracted pelves, the anthropoid type,
It may be better to deliver the occiput posterior as such, over the perineum. But as a rule, it is best to do the rotation.
Again, it may be impossible to effect delivery with the forceps.
And then, you should not use dangerous force, but consider the three alternatives.
First, version. Now, version is an unorthodox procedure, after you have tried the forceps.
Second, craniotomy.
Third, laparotrachelotomy.
[Observer 2:] Doctor, why do you prefer silkworm gut?
[Dr. DeLee:] Some of you may think I am old-fashioned, because I use and recommend
the figure of eight silkworm gut stitches in the perineum.
But, long experience has convinced me that it is the safest for general practice.
True, catgut makes prettier wounds and does not hurt the patient so much.
But remember, we obstetricians are working in an infected field, between feces and urine.
Remember too that catgut is treacherous. It sometimes is absorbed too quickly.
And furthermore, the knots uncurl.
Third, I use catgut, but only in a perfectly aseptic environment.
Fourth, drainage.
If you have sewn a wound with catgut, and it becomes infected, it is very hard to drain.
Whereas, if you have used silkworm gut, you cut the stitches and then you can lay the wound wide open to the bowel.
[Observer 3:] Doctor, why did you forbid Kristeller expression?
[Dr. DeLee:] Kristeller expression interferes with the mechanism of labor and may hurt the baby.
Second, it mashes the placenta, and disturbs the mechanism of the placental delivery.
Third, it bruises the uterus, and bruises invite infection, thrombosis, and embolism.
Fourth, it is unnecessary.
To me, it appears brutal, midwifery, not obstetrics.
I have yet to take up forceps in cases of face and brow presentation and other mechanisms.
But today I will show you a case of forceps on the aftercoming head.
Mrs. L, age 29, primipara sacral left, transverse.
I did a complete extraction. The film, please.
Anyone wants a more convincing demonstration of the indispensability of the tracheal catheter,
and of the value of the forceps on the aftercoming head.
Now, ladies and gentlemen, in conclusion.
This instrument is one of the most beneficent gifts that the art of medicine has given to humanity.
Correctly indicated, and skillfully applied, it fulfills its primary function,
which is to deliver the baby, by the head, without injury to it or its mother.
Indeed, we may go a little further. In expert hands, and in a proper environment,
it may be used to diminish those injuries which even natural labor sometimes inflicts upon the mother and child.
And this is what I tried to do with the prophylactic forceps operation.
On the other hand, if the instrument is used indiscriminately, without proper indication,
and before the conditions are all satisfied, it can work irreparable damage on both mother and baby.
The operation of forceps itself, can be developed to the highest point of technical beauty and safety.
And this will help to raise the art of obstetrics to a high level
and confer upon it that dignity which the science of obstetrics has prepared for it.